want to confirm our breaking news this
afternoon that the second victim of the
London Bridge terror attack has been
named as 23 year old Saskia Jones says
the first image of her she was from
stratford-upon-avon in Warwickshire
saskia we're hearing from her family
this afternoon a statement released via
the Metropolitan Police Saskia was a
funny kind positive influence at the
center of many people's lives she had a
wonderful sense of mischievous fun and
was generous to the point of always
wanting to see the best in all people
the statement goes on she was intent on
living life to the full and had
wonderful thirst for knowledge enabling
her to be the best she could be Saskia
had a great passion for providing
invaluable support to victims of
criminal injustice which led her to the
point of recently applying for the
police graduate recruitment programme
wishing to specialize in victim support
so this is 23 year old Saskia Jones
there we now know she was a volunteer at
this learning together event near London
Bridge fishmongers Hall it was on Friday
afternoon when as muncom started his
attack the other victim was Jack Merritt
who we named yesterday
he's a 25 year old from Cottenham in
Cambridge and we've heard more from his
family today we'd heard from his father
yesterday his family releasing another
statement saying Jack Merritt our
beautiful talented boy died doing what
he loved
surrounded by people he loved and who
loved him he lit up our lives and lives
of his many friends and colleagues and
we will miss him terribly we know Jack
Merritt was a coordinator at this
learning together program and as I say
Saskia Jones was a volunteer there she
was 23 and from stratford-upon-avon in
Warwickshire we're hearing more today
from the University vice-chancellor
Cambridge University professor Stephen -
he had disclosed that one of the three
people injured by as mongkhon before he
was restrained on Friday was a member of
staff a current member of staff at the
University so three people in total were
injured we now know one of them is out
of hospital and the two others remain in
a stable condition and are told they're
continuing to receive experts care so
that's the latest developments on this
fast-moving story at the to victim's
name there we know jack merits 25 from
Cottenham in Cambridgeshire named
yesterday and in the past few minutes we
have named Saskia Jones the other victim
she was 23 from stratford-upon-avon and
a volunteer at the learning together
program